welcome back to Las Vegas now so if you
want to leave the cooking to someone
else for Hanukkah this year Hearthstone
at Red Rock Casino has you covered and
here to show us what they are cooking up
we have Robert morgenthal of Click
hospitality and Donald Thompson of
hearthstone thank you guys so much for
being here thanks for inviting us of
course so before we started the
interview I was telling you I go to
Hearthstone all the time it's one of my
favorite restaurants but for people who
haven't been there before how would you
describe it I would say Hearthstone is a
stylish rustic American Eatery
everything's homemade by Chef doll and
his team we have some really cool dishes
and also some really cool craft
cocktails yeah Chef Donald I'm grateful
for you because the food is delicious
every time I go there but you guys are
doing something special for Hanukkah you
have a full menu tell us what's on the
menu through the rest of the week all
right we have our traditional Hanukkah
Classics one of our appetizers is our
potato latkes with smoked salmon Dill
creme fresh homemade applesauce we also
have some hola knots with some honey
butter and for our a main course we have
our red wine braised
brisket topped with a red wine Demi root
vegetables and crispy potatoes on top
and not to forget for dessert we have
our homemade chocolate babka bread
pudding with chocolate on top caramel
sauce and caramel glaze on the bottom a
must-have if you're coming to
Hearthstone this holiday yeah I was just
going to say
everything is delicious and I heard you
talking
it's so popular right yes last night was
our first night and we actually sold out
in the first three hours I did not
anticipate being so busy but we went in
early this morning and prepped up so
we're ready for everybody please come
and try our dishes so you have more
waiting absolutely because I'm coming
for that and I have had a lot of potato
latkes in my life but I've never had
them so fancy like that so was it fun to
kind of put a you know a trendy spin on
the traditional dish I feel like it's
beautiful no absolutely that's one of
the things that we do at Hearthstone we
take something simple and then kind of
elevate it a little bit to bring it to
our guests you know it's not what your
grandma would make but like pretty much
but from a chef's perspective with a
little bit of fine dining finesse in
there yeah well you guys do a great job
and in addition to Hanukkah you have
some other celebrations coming up
Christmas New Year's right you guys are
doing it all every time there's
something coming up any holiday
Valentine's Day also is coming around
the corner right so if you want to plant
it obviously reservations is highly
recommended because we do you know run
out of table space right we do have a
really nice pack patio obviously winter
time is really cold for that so
definitely please make reservations be
open seven days a week
four o'clock for dinner we do have
brunch starting at 10 A.M in the morning
and you guys have live music sometimes
too right not the reason to stay inside
because I love just coming in there you
can spend all night in there you get
lost in time you guys thank you so much
for being here I'm really excited to
come try out the menu and uh save me one
of those later okay be sure to go visit
Hearthstone at Red Rock Casino you won't
be disappointed JC over to you